sometimes people ask me how do i feel
about black holes i do find them scary
intimidating well they they are a bit
but they can't be cuddly too these are
two
cuddly toy black holes that i got as a
present for my sister-in-law i just i
just like them they're just a little
cuddly thing there's a little baby one
and there's a slightly bigger you know
mummy black hole if you like
oh well a black hole is a
region of space
in which
light can't escape from material comes
together under the force of gravity
tries to fight that
but if you get too much material you
can't overcome that force
and eventually mathematics and the laws
of physics take us into this strange
regime well it's an object which which
forms when a star dies
something that's got many masses of the
sun has collapsed under its own
gravitational pull we've got a lot of
mass packed in a very small region
eventually it collapses to the point
where not even light can escape from it
and it forms something called an event
horizon but it's like a shell if you
like
and that event horizon is the
within that event horizon light can't
escape
so that's why it's black at the center
it has this mathematical impossibility
called the singularity so they say black
girls can't have hair well these ones do
and eyes do you know what i like to make
the earth into a black hole you'd
actually have to make it about that yeah
yeah that's right yeah so if that was
really a black hole it would be probably
more massive than the earth contained
within that little tiny region here on
earth if you throw something up in the
air it comes back down again okay and if
you throw it a bit harder it goes a bit
higher but it will tend to come back
down again if you throw something hard
enough it'll actually escape from the
earth entirely
a rocket
doesn't have to be i mean you know you
could fire a projectile up or anything
as long as it's travelling at this
escape velocity escape speed it will
escape from the earth's gravity keep
going and going and going off to
infinity rather than eventually turning
around and coming back if you were to
make the earth a bit more compressed
then the gravitational pull would get a
bit more intense and so actually you'd
have to throw something a bit harder to
get it to escape from the earth pull
gravity if you kept squishing the earth
and squishing the earth eventually you'd
reach a point where the gravitational
pull was so strong that that escape
velocity became equal to the speed of
light and because we can't get anything
to go at the speed of light apart from
light and in particular we definitely
can't get anything to go faster than
light that means if you then squish it a
tiny bit more then nothing can escape
not even light can escape nothing can
escape from it because suddenly in order
to escape from it you have to make
something travel faster than light in
order to do so but a black hole in
general relativity is actually even more
sinister than that it's not just that
light can't escape a black hole in gr
there is literally no way to get out of
it
if it was just a matter of the escape
velocity being high you could always
build a ladder climb out of it and with
a sufficiently powerful rocket get away
but there's actually more to it than
that space and time
collapses in on itself as you enter the
event horizon of a black hole and gr and
there's literally no way to escape from
it now we all know black holes involve
these things called singularities but
from what you're saying it sounds like
you don't have to get as far as a
singularity to get to a point where
light can't escape it could be quite a
lot bigger than a singularity indeed and
in fact so these the the kind of the
thought experiment i've just gone
through predates general relativity by a
long time i think probably laplace or
someone was the first people who person
who actually thought this through and
realized there was a point where you
would create a thing called a black hole
and then you know if you if just dealing
with newtonian gravity you still have a
black you know you can create black
holes it's only when you then say okay
so what when you try and solve the set
of equations as to what's going on
within general relativity when you've
gone through this process that's when
you realize that you actually create a
singularity by doing that in gr space
and time becomes
compressed such that any movement you
make in time or space
takes you towards the center of the
thing and actually that's what led uh
hawking and penrose in the late 60s to
suggest that you have to have a
singularity at the center of a black
hole essentially and then eventually
your equations inevitably break down and
so you have to
the very existence of black holes and
the singularity that you
seemed it looks like you have at the
center of them tells you that einstein's
theory is not a complete theory it's at
best an effective theory that needs to
be replaced by something else when you
start talking about
you know high energies strong
gravitational fields and so on and so
forth even when you get to photons
things with no mass at all they still
get pulled by gravity and we can see
that directly through this phenomenon
called gravitational lensing that where
you've got like light from something
passing a massive body probably a galaxy
or something like that you can actually
see that the path of light has been bent
by gravity and so actually gravity is
affecting even light its path is being
diverted by it so it's being pulled by
the gravitational field so even light's
not immune to gravity now the thing
that's different
is that light doesn't slow down because
light always travels at the speed of
light so if you think about you know
you're on one of these incredibly
compact objects and you're shining a
light upwards and saying what happens
it's not like throwing a rock in the air
that it comes back down again with light
it will keep traveling away from you at
the speed of light but it's using up
energy right the another way to think
about these things is the energy that
you're turning the kinetic energy of
something if it's a rock into its
potential energy as it goes away from
the surface it's the same with light but
the way that light loses its energy
isn't by slowing down the way that light
loses its energy is by changing color it
would lose its energy by changing color
by you know starting at the blue end of
the spectrum and ending up at the red
end of the spectrum and then beyond red
it would turn infrared radio waves and
actually before it escaped it would have
used up all its energy and kind of
redshifted to nothingness there'll be no
energy left to escape
so
little lone black holes which we call
stellar mass black holes can be one of
the several endpoints to the evolution
of a star they're by no means the most
common end point so most stars like our
own sun will turn into a white dwarf at
the end of their life and then fade into
basically nothingness if you have a star
that's massive enough and the mass of
the star governs pretty much its entire
life
it will either turn into a neutron star
through a supernova or if it's even more
massive it'll turn into an even denser
object which is the black hole and so
you know there are a lot of stars out
there so there are a lot of black holes
out there um but they're no i know means
sort of ubiquitous and and littering the
galaxy we know there's always gravity so
there's always something pulling things
together
so the the sort of sometimes the more
salient question is what stops
everything collapsing into black holes
and so for example in something like the
sun you've got the nuclear fusion in the
middle which is producing the energy
which is heating things up which is kind
of keeping it puffed up but if you were
to turn off that nuclear fusion then the
sun would start to collapse down
and gravity would pull it and pull it
and pull it and then you say okay so
what else could stop it i've no longer
got my source of fusion and it turns out
there are a few things that might help
out
so there's this thing called electron
degeneracy pressure
um which is you know which is a very
electrons basically don't like being
squashed close together and so electron
degeneracy pressure will stop something
like the sun from collapsing all the way
to a black hole it'll turn it into a
thing called a white dwarf which is held
up by electron degeneracy pressure turns
out if it was a bit more massive then
either an electron degeneracy pressure
wouldn't do it gravity would win again
so it would say to hell with this squash
all the electrons together and then it
would collapse down further to kind of
nuclear density at that point you create
a thing called a neutron star and
there's a thing called neutron
degeneracy pressure which is that
neutrons don't like being squashed very
close together either um
and so that will halt the collapse and
you end up with a neutron star but then
it's a little bit more massive than that
so maybe about twice the mass of the sun
bit more than that then even electron
even the neutron degeneracy pressure
won't stop it and then it will keep
collapsing and then as far as we know
there's nothing that will stop that
collapse now maybe we're missing some
physics maybe there is some process we
don't know about which would actually
hold that collapse but we don't know
what it is but they're the boring ones
let me tell you about the interesting
ones the interesting ones are the ones
that live in the middle of galaxies
which are enormous they're very very
massive
indeed and so that process goes on as
well and in fact when we see these
brightness